how you doing guys we have today 2019
Ford Explorer and we're going to add
another proximity key to the vehicle's
memory let's start
so I'm gonna use a hotel km100 Key
machine and I'm going to connect the
dongle to the OBD right underneath the
steering column and this is going to be
connected via Bluetooth to the machine
we're going to turn on the machine we're
going to go to immobilizer
we're gonna go to Ford
I'm going to go to automatic selection
and we're going to read the VIN number
the ignition needs to be on on position
and we're gonna hit OK
it's gonna decode the entire system and
we're gonna hit smart key because we
have a push to start
we're going to hit yes
and we're going to go to
hot function
we're going to go to add key we're going
to hit start we'll hit OK because there
is no alarm system on and we're gonna
take the new key and we're going to put
it in the center console
right in the slot in order to write the
new one we'll hit yes
we'll hit again yes to make sure the
ignition is on on position and hit OK
the system is going to go to security
mode and I'm gonna fast forward
[Music]
and it's going to finish the procedure
and it says learn Keys too
tells us to put the key in the slot and
the key is already in the slot we're
going to hit OK
we're going to hear the door cycle to
let us know that it registered the next
key and it's going to read the new keys
we have three in the memory and it's a
success so we're gonna pull up the new
key out of the slot and we're gonna go
and test all the buttons to make sure
everything is working properly and it
should looks like that
foreign
we're gonna go from the outside and make
sure that the lock and unlock buttons
everything work
we're going to test it also on the trunk
to make sure the buttons of the trunks
are working the way it should
and everything looks nice and easy
the last thing we need to test is to
make sure that the car starts
proximity works so you can unlock the
door
and
thank you very much now I'm going to
demonstrate how to cut the blade as well
so stay tuned and we'll see how to cut
the key
I'm going to use the SEC E9 high
security key machine I'm going to put
the original key inside the machine and
I'm going to go to the menu hit search
I'm going to look for ago 101 which is
the blade for Ford it's 10 cuts so I'm
going to hit the 10 cuts I'm going to
hit the code and the Machine is going to
the code the original key
that way we can cut the new key
when it finished the coating we're going
to remove the original key and I'm going
to slide the new blade out of the new
foam
and we're gonna cut the key
[Music]
thank you